merci au président driss de nous avoir
permis d'organiser ici avec le site et
du nice et s'est assise parce que c'est
évidemment un temps fort la vienne est
historiquement engagé ça a été rappelé
par mon collector des jeunes avec le
burkina faso parce que le président
monory en 67 ans a fait ce premier
jumelage nord foot c'est un événement et
ça me fait particulièrement plaisir que
le maire de ouagadougou soit ici parce
que les liens sont forts et on le
confirme ce matin par cette présence et
voilà derrière cette histoire on se rend
bien compte que c'est aujourd'hui toute
une région qui est concerné s'il n'y a
pas de volonté des gouvernements bien
évidemment cette zone du monde sera
complexe mais je sais qu'il ya en tout
cas une volonté partagée
et puis l'autre chance et la
décentralisation des sensations parce
que c'est aux élus que vous n'êtes que
nous sommes partout de construire les
échanges de reconstruire là où il ya
besoin de trouver les outils les projets
qui vont permettre à vos populations de
continuer à rester là où ils souhaitent
vivre les uns de ces assises constituent
ces fêtes tremplin idéal du promotion
d'une nouvelle forme de coopération
multipartite multi partenarial qui
semble convaincu malgré les actions
d'une mode et monde municipal dans sa
globalité
désormais tous nous sommes passés d'une
logique pays et une logique régionale et
que nous pensons sel et c'est très
important parce que on le voit bien
certain nombre d'outils internationaux
sont désormais dimensionné à l'échelle
sahélienne il était important et bien
que au niveau des territoires également
et des représentations territoriale nous
ayons cette même cette même
cette même vision la coopération
décentralisée doit demeurer au-delà des
agents d'armes locaux des difficultés
locales des contraintes budgétaires et
de l'insécurité ambiante
il ya un adage qui dit nul n'est trop
pauvre pour n'avoir rien à partager
changeons de lunettes essayons de
bousculer les procédures ne sont pas
prisonniers des procédures essayons de
les adapter au moment donc si cette
étape de poitiers est un moment de
solidarité
j'espère qu'il faudrait donner un
contenu et particulier chez la gazelle
c'est surtout qu'on fabrique localement
au burkina faso donc aujourd'hui on est
les seuls la seule entreprise a fabriqué
en afrique des produits solaires par
rapport aux autres entreprises qui font
tous fabriqués en chine
tous les discours nous avons des maires
du sahel ces biens ne fait pas sans nous
on a aussi des capacités à répondre ne
sommes pas là qu'a demandé on est là
aussi à pouvoir apporter des expertises
apporter des solutions de pour ça faut
qu'on soit dans la boucle de là pour que
la dette puisse aussi jouer tout son
rôle d'agent de 200 billets d'ensemblier
ici et de facilitateur aussi d'un
certain nombre de démarches de puisqu'il
faut un ambassadeur
je ne sais quoi est-ce qu'il faut une
équipe en tout cas qu'ils soient en
capacité claire rassembler ce me semble
indispensable au fond nous en sommes
aujourd'hui donc une équipe moteur
fédérateur une locomotive sous des
formes ayant inventé mais en tout cas
une vraie dynamique
merci à tous le burkina faso
l'illustrent parfaitement
pourtant le pays des hommes intègres
c'est face à de nombreuses difficultés
les collectivités territoriales
françaises vont jouer un rôle moteur sur
deux deux plans un plusieurs ou de
coopération décentralisée qui existe
déjà mais c est elles vont jouer un rôle
août
mais ces collectivités qui n'ont qui ont
déjà une coopération décentralisée ont
en voisinage
d'autres collectivités qui n'ont pas dû
coopération décentralisée mais qu'elles
peuvent impliquer dans ses projets pour
avoir plus d'acteurs et ai donc essayé
d'amener ces collectivités qui n'ont pas
de coopération décentralisée qu'elle le
soit au niveau de la france surtout mais
qu'elle ne soit dans d autres pays
peuvent être rejoindre
c'est ces initiatives et par le biais
d'actions menées par les collectivités
territoriales françaises
il y a à l'autre il faut expliquer
d'ailleurs il faut toujours se baser sur
des initiatives multi acteurs et donc il
faut surtout impliquer les mouvements
associatifs locaux qui sont intéressés
et qui sont dans les collectivités
territoriales françaises est extrêmement
intéressant dans cette dans cette
coopération parce qu'il s'agit d'une
coopération c'est que y'a et on l'a dit
tout à l'heure des échanges avec un
certain nombre de professionnels
médecins sages-femmes logisticiens vont
à moundou et des spécialistes de la
maternité de différents domaines vienne
à poitiers
et il ya ces échanges et au fil du temps
ce qui est sans doute la matrice de tout
ça est ce qui a permis que les choses
évoluent d'une manière satisfaisante au
fil des années donc 20 ans pour la santé
30 ans pour l'association c'est très
certainement la qualité des relations
qui ont été établis entre les
professionnels
on connaît les professionnels de moundou
ils nous connaissent
on a des relations lorsqu'on est sur
place et lorsqu'ils sont ici mais on a
aussi des relations entre temps et on a
des échanges
régulièrement je pense que
nous vivons cette insécurité au
quotidien maintenant il s'agit de plans
des risques et je crois que ces risques
ils sont nécessaires et ils sont
d'autant plus nécessaire d'apprendre que
c'est apporter une réponse assez que le
présent macro indigènes et répété hier
il ya quelques semaines aux nations
unies et sur le temps du courage et de
la responsabilité
c'est le cas du collège il faut tout
explorer et n'a le monopole de la
traçabilité
mais nous sommes des hommes devront
conjuguer nos intelligences pour trouver
les solutions justement novatrice face à
l'adversité
la nouvelle cité n'est de l'exécuter du
ou 10 à 10 mhz au banditisme et à toute
sorte de d'agression dans le sahel est
l'objet je pense que c'est dans notre
camp aujourd'hui au mali au burkina au
niger au tchad à des hommes et des
femmes qui prennent le risque de faire
face et ce en conjuguant nos
intelligences que nous trouverons des
solutions et je pense que nous devrons
plus que nos efforts en se disant que
nul n'a le monopole du savoir et savoir
faire à la suite de la concertation et
de la noce de la tenue de deux ans à 6
ans en territoire malien de mali à
bamako en octobre 2021
[Applaudissements]